welcome back to this special edition of
hannity the department of justice is
taking heat this week after attorney
general merrick garland directed the fbi
to prepare strategies for addressing
unruly parents
at school board meetings the republican
members of the senate judiciary
committee did not like the sound of that
so they sent a letter to garland asking
that he reassure us americans that our
own department of justice won't be
infringing on our first amendment rights
to free speech
and biden's problems go far beyond just
parents who are upset with critical race
theory black leaders are starting to
lose patience with joe pointing out that
he's saddled vice president kamala
harris with solving all of the
administration's worst problems
back with us our fox news contributors
leo terrell and lisa booth we had some
technical difficulty with dr ben carson
tonight uh thanks for bringing us back
for joining us again leo i want to start
with you because to get the department
of justice involved and engaged with
school board meetings
how do they justify this
you can't and as a lawyer as a civil
rights lawyer you cannot this is pure
intimidation jason look let's be clear
critical race theory is racist and
parents at the local level have a first
amendment right to address their local
school boards these are local issues and
what i find insulting is we're ignoring
the fact that critical race theory is
trying to teach our kids to be little
racist individuals and these parents are
fighting back they have a direct right a
say-so in the curriculum and what their
kids are being taught at school this is
all part of a federalized game in
conjunction with the national teachers
union to basically indoctrinate our kids
on how to hate each other i find it
offensive not only as a civil rights
attorney not only as a lawyer but as a
former school teacher it is outrageous
lisa i don't believe there's any federal
jurisdiction to get the fbi involved in
our local school board meeting but once
word gets out on this how do you think
the next school board meeting is
actually going to go when there's an
open meeting and they actually open up
the mics and let the parents talk about
how they're going to educate their own
children
well first of all the whole point of
critical race theory for the left is
that if you say the country is
inherently racist racist if it's rooted
in slavery then the country is easier to
destroy it makes it easier to burn down
the ground that's what the left is
trying to do with that but look parents
need to double down right now is the
time we're not just creeping towards
communism in america we the democrats
have hit their foot the pedal on the
accelerator towards communist and
communism an authoritarian nation i mean
think about it the doj and the fbi are
not targeting parents in america and we
had the fbi recently sit before congress
and said they're not tracking left-wing
violence like antifa but what's on their
radar parents in america it's because
the system is falling apart and it's
starting with the schools you have
parents standing up for their kids you
have 1.5 million students or more have
been pulled out of government-run
schools homeschooling has tripled since
pre-pandemic levels because people are
seeing the indoctrination the things
that their children are being taught and
they're standing up for it so they're
trying to preserve the system and that's
why now they're getting the doj and the
fbi
involved because otherwise the public
school system will fall apart that now
that parents know what is actually going
on in these schools
yeah i think they're inadvertently
making the case for school choice along
the way but i i think you're right i
think it's time for for parents to
double down uh leo i got to get your
very quick take though there's been some
criticism out there of what joe biden is
giving kamala harris to work on there's
some black leaders out there thinking
that he's giving her all the real
difficult things the things you that are
that are really hard like immigration
and voter suppression and all those
types of things and they're complaining
instead of giving her the softballs that
she supposedly wants
is it's totally pandering look she is in
the vice president's scene she should be
able to handle every type of job on the
planet she is the second most powerful
person in the world and let me be clear
but she's not qualified she's not
competent and i have no doubt to say
this i'm more confident she is so those
black leaders who have whoever they are
jason they don't represent me they don't
represent black americans there's no
black voice for all people kamala harris
should stand up and do something and so
far her nine months have been disastrous
she hasn't had one accomplishment she's
horrible did i say horrible she's
horrible
yeah no i i think this is the problem
with biden and harris nine months in
they have no they they they have no
successes to to point to and they're
poor communicators so
thank you again for joining us on this
second block as well
all right more of this special edition
of hannity
right after the break stay with us